now unfortunately the first doctor
didn't have a sonic screwdriver so this
left to do
so I've recommends something that I've
been putting up while not putting off
but having a hard time finding time to
do and I'm gonna try and integrate it
into the channel as you may have noticed
pretty much all my doctor who lists up
to this point have been focused entirely
almost entirely at least on knew who
that is because there are significant
gaps in my classic who knowledge I've
seen samples of all the doctors I've
seen what are generally considered to be
the best episodes of classic era but
there's still a lot of holes and there's
a lot of all significant stories that
maybe aren't always considered to be the
best but I still haven't seen before so
this is me starting what will I'm gonna
say an occasional no I'm no commitment
for how often I'm gonna get around to
this but reviews of classic error
stories as I either revisit them because
I haven't seen them for a very long time
or see them for the first time and share
my feelings about them now even though I
am going to be starting with the very
first Doctor Who story this is not a
commitment for me to do this in
chronological order I don't think that's
gonna happen I'm more likely going to
jump around to whatever I feel like at
the time or whatever I happen to get my
hands on so I really do want to try and
keep a fairly steady stream of Doctor
Who related content going I am well
aware that that is how most people have
found my channel that's what most people
are here to see so I have no illusions
about that even though I try and keep up
a fairly steady diet of other material
as well but I as much as I've sort of
decided for myself I want and that one
video a week to be Doctor Who related I
also don't want to keep eating up that
time with list because I've got a number
of lists still planned but I don't want
to burn through those ideas and start
just making stupid lists for the sake of
it you know just dumb premises so in the
interest of doing no
more than two lists a month if that at
all this is the sort of thing that will
probably fill in when doctor who is not
airing new stuff and there's been no
news that's broken so with all of that
preamble out of the way way more than is
probably necessary let's talk about the
unearthly child which is generally what
we now call the first four episodes of
Doctor Who because for a while they were
that each episode had individual names
as opposed to later where they just
called it by one story then was part 1
part 2 part 3 etc um I I should say up
front also with these classic reviews I
I am gonna talk spoilers I mean this is
all really crazy old stuff I'm in this
particular case I don't expect I'm gonna
get like deep into anything that is
supposed to be surprising over the
course of story but yeah I'm not gonna
be wary of them I actually had only seen
clips of this one the first um the
initial first doctor story that I saw
was the Daleks which is the second one
but if I ever talk about that what I
need to re-watch it it's been a very
long time my favorite of the first
doctor stories that I've seen because
I've seen a couple others I've seen the
time meddler I saw the Aztecs my
favorite though is Dalek invasion of
Earth but this one I actually had not
seen front-to-back before just clips
from it usually almost entirely from the
first episode out of the four so I
didn't I didn't have a ton of
expectation I really wasn't entirely
sure what I was gonna get I was
tempering my expectations though because
as much as I do enjoy classic era Doctor
Who a lot of it is really dated now in
talking about this episode and classic
episodes in general I'm gonna try really
hard to be fair to them and by that I
mean I'm not holding them to modern
standards so I'm gonna try and just not
you know linger too much on wonky you
know sort of costuming if the effects
and things like that unless I think it
is bad even for the time I might point
that out but for the most part I
really want to focus on the story in the
characters because that's that's the
stuff that's timeless regardless of of
you know whatever else has happened and
you know better effects better costumes
color things like that so I was
surprised actually at how good this
first story was I'm not gonna expect it
to be bad but I mean you know it's it's
cavemen that's kind of the really I when
you when you have a time-travel device
that's kind of the really obvious thing
is to go back to the Stone Age so I
wasn't expecting a ton out of it
especially knowing it was the first
story I figure they were probably gonna
be stumbling points but the first
admittedly out of the four episodes that
comprise this whole story the first one
is the best and its really surprising
watching it now as someone who you know
obviously has seen samplings of all the
doctor and got hooked in initially I
knew who it's really fascinating how
much of a I don't want to say malevolent
but a an untrustworthy an unsettling
figure the doctor is in his initial
appearance like almost everything about
him reads more as potential antagonist
than possible future protagonist I mean
it seems very clear over the course of
story that that Ian is the more
traditional hero of the story you know
he's the he's the take-charge guy and
he's the one who tries to impart wisdom
to this this leader of the of the
cavemen and the doctor himself is very
standoffish which I mean I expected I've
seen her t'l before but just not only in
the way he was performed but the way he
is presented like knowing there's no
history for this guy like everything
about him sets off a danger warning his
standoffish missus snappish this how
secretive he is and it's also really
interesting to watch that he's not
nearly as on the ball as we're used to
seeing especially in new who I mean III
think it's
it's a criticism largely leveled by fans
who grew up on classic who that the
doctor kind of is too you know together
and with it and always on top of things
in new who and I think that's arguable
one way or the other but regardless of
whether you feel that's the case it's
certainly interesting to go back and see
a story where like he really was caught
flat-footed he was not prepared for this
at all and like and all these things
that are obviously throwing him off for
the first time or he's still getting a
handle on like the fact that he only
just notices that the chameleon circuit
isn't working they don't even call it
that yet but you know it's still the
police box even though they've gone back
in time so he realizes that's not
working he doesn't know where they've
landed until he goes out to collect
samples that he would then have to test
he doesn't just step out sniff the air
know the planet that the the galaxy the
time period and the current season you
know it's it's interesting and it
doesn't make either end feel wrong it's
just interesting knowing
oh he's gonna develop from this that
I've seen now into what I'm used to
seeing in the more modern era um in
terms of the other characters in a
Barbara at least as they get initially
introduced work really well I think it
helps that you know Ian as much as he
kind of becomes a slightly more generic
take-charge
Marion kind of character as the story
goes on initially I mean we see him just
being pleasant you know with Barbara
they have nice banner they have good
chemistry that doesn't feel like forced
romantic chemistry which is kind of nice
and Barbara has has a strong moral sense
she's more open-minded than him she she
has a protective streak towards Susan
Susan in the first episode was actually
kind of fascinating to me because I feel
like she did a really good job of
channeling the frustration of somebody
who knows way more than this school
could actually teach her and yet misses
all the all the weird little details
that someone who just is of this time
No and her frustration with that and and
also in that first episode in particular
she she is a little weird she's a little
off-putting she's a little alien and you
get why Ian and Barbara would have his
curiosity about her cuz she acts weird
she knows weird stuff and that is a
really good hook this idea of there's
this girl on our school she's a little
weird and she knows stuff that doesn't
make sense for her to know let's find
out what's going on there that's just a
really interesting starting place and
hook and especially you know introducing
the doctor she says he's her grandfather
but you don't know if that's really the
case you don't know if he's somehow I'm
you know keeping her imprisoned in some
way I mean with his demeanor it wouldn't
be a huge shock so all of that the first
episode of this as far as I'm concerned
is solid gold it I mean like I'm stunned
how good it is the rest of the story
once they actually started interacting
with the cavemen is weaker but not as
bad as I was afraid it was gonna be for
starters actually the cavemen themselves
are surprisingly compelling I think a
big part of what helped is really until
the very end you don't have a firm grasp
on who the quote-unquote good guy
is in this tribe because you've got za
and Cal and you know and and the and the
old woman and the younger woman and and
they're all just interacting they're all
just trying to survive and it isn't a
case of oh this one's the good one this
one's the bad ones like I get where
everybody's coming from and certainly
relative to the doctor and the others
they all these people are a problem and
like and I kept going back and forth so
and initially I'm like oh I really I
really sympathize with this guy's out
who's trying to start the fire and he
can't and he's frustrated oh this other
guy Cal he's coming in to to take over I
bet you cows like the usurper and stuff
but then you know Cal you know set some
stuff he's front and center and you're
like oh well you you're not like the
archetypal villain
that I was expecting and then za starts
doing some stuff that you're like oh
you're gonna be the problem and then
like the woman kind of whispering in his
ear she's like she's almost got a lady
Macbeth thing going but then you know
they save him like oh well he'll just be
on on the doctor and the companions I
not except he kinda isn't he's still a
problem
I there was a surprising amount of
nuance to everything that was going on
with them I and the sort of the stunted
broken English way of speaking didn't
grate on me the way that usually does
with that sort of typical very dated way
of depicting people from that period in
time but it didn't grant on me nearly as
much I think they just found a really
good balance of more or less complete
sentences and then more broken up ones
they they they kind of went back and
forth but not so much that it felt like
it was inconsistent it just it got the
point but game but didn't Hammer you
with it I think there's a genuine
weakness to be had it's it's in kind of
a a bit of a D evolution of Barbara and
Susan well D evolution for Barbara and
then Susan
unfortunately that Susan gets hysterical
a lot and quickly and it gets old really
quick and it's kind of off-putting
especially considering that you know she
she travels with the doctor and you know
maybe she's not used to being in these
types of dangerous situations this isn't
the life he's leading yet but at the
same time given that you know she's
still from this society and and from a
life that knows these things she the the
speed with which she leaps to panic is
kind of irritating now it makes a
certain degree of sense for how young
she is she's probably you know a little
bit cocky and then things go wrong ah
help so I mean I get it it makes sense
but boy she screams a lot and then I
think it was starting in the third
episode
Barbara started get going hysterical as
well which was first of all unnecessary
because we have a historical character
already in Susan to have a second
terrico character is redundant but
beyond that it did feel like a D
evolution for her specifically because
she had you know she had a more open
mind she was more able to sort of roll
with what was going on to not just be in
denial about it but to think about it
but once things got dangerous then she
starts panicking and the man has to get
in there and be a man and you know it's
it's a little disappointing I mean you
know era that it was made in I get it I
absolutely do but especially considering
that she started out from a stronger
position and again I had two historical
characters is completely redundant it's
just it's a little disappointing but
overall it it's a lot better than I
thought it was gonna be like it's like
it's genuinely good there's a there are
a lot of times where I well not a lot
but there have been a number of times
where I've seen classic era episodes and
I've been I've come away going and that
was alright I'm not sure I'd recommend
it to anybody who hasn't already seen it
or you know isn't trying to be a
completist about it that there's a lot
of things that I would kind of toss on
the eye you can skip that one pile and I
kind of expected this to land there and
it doesn't I mean it's genuinely really
good unfortunately the the ladder and
well the the last 75% of the story is
not as strong as the opening quarter of
it that but that first episode Wow
I mean that's gripping and compelling
and the characters are engaging and it's
just really really good and then once it
gets into the story proper it's a little
weaker but it's still good and better
than I thought it was gonna be given the
material it didn't drag nearly as much
as I thought it would either so I was I
was really pleasantly surprised about
this I mean the the excessive use of the
hysterical female stereotype is really
kind of my only complaint about this the
rest of it is either good or if nothing
else just really fascinating I mean Ida
left
I literally watched a situation where
the doctor threw the first stone that
weird but kind of interesting so I think
that's about it for this like I said I
don't know when I'll do another classic
era review I doubt it will be the next
one in order I don't think I'm that
committed to doing it like that but
we'll see what happens in any case those
are my thoughts on an unearthly child
have you seen it what did you think
about the very first Doctor Who story
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that is
available on Apple podcast and on
stitcher radio I'm also one half of the
punch like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network Fire and Water podcast
comm links for all the stuff is down
below and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]